foreign
Is With Us in Kansas City hey Evan
what's up
hey Dave I got a heck of a mess on my
hands and I could use your advice on how
to tackle it we'll try what's up okay so
uh my mom has pretty well squandered all
her money her whole life about five
years ago she inherited four hundred
thousand dollars for my grandparents and
between my siblings stealing it and
um her squandering it it's pretty well
all gone and she never has really taken
care of herself her whole life and my
siblings want to have a conversation on
Thanksgiving about putting her in a
nursing home because her health is that
bad and I'll be honest with you Dave I'm
just to the point I don't want to pay
for it I mean she's made a lot of
horrible mistakes in her life I have two
I'm on track to pay off all my debt in
the next six months and I just I'm kind
of wondering how you would best approach
that conversation or that situation
I'm sorry how old is she
ah she's about 62.
ancient
what what's what what what is she my age
well what's what's her health condition
because you said that she she's in bad
Health what is it like early Alzheimer's
or is it what
no it's it's very overweight I mean she
got so heavy one point her knee started
to hurt and so instead of losing weight
she bought an electric wheelchair so she
didn't have to walk anywhere and she
just it's just it's going downhill okay
pretty fast my sister lives with her now
and it's to the point where she can't
take care of her and it's it's this I
know I've seen this coming I don't know
my siblings have but I have seen this
coming yeah okay is she she is destitute
she has no money
an account
well so here's the she does own a site
at a campground and she does own a house
but you know we could sell that for a
little while but that's only going to
last so long
okay because the house isn't worth
anything I mean we can get maybe 20 000
out of it and maybe two or three
thousand out of this campsite that she
owns yeah okay so she doesn't okay so
here's the thing
um what you guys need to study and you
need to do a little study on it before
you get to Thanksgiving is uh there
there's welfare nursing home it's called
Medicaid
and it will not take her house it will
make her sell the campground and apply
that but after that Social Security
basically pays Medicaid pays for her
nursing home and she goes to a Medicaid
nursing home it's government funded now
um it's not it's not as
fancy schmancy as if you're paying 80
grand a year to be there you know
okay yeah but uh but but she'll be okay
I mean they'll feed her and take care of
her and
um and if she needs care she can go into
a Medicaid nursing home and
um and it sounds like that none of you
are multi-millionaires
no um I'm probably the most Financial
off
um and the part of the issue too is I
mean we're having this conversation at
Thanksgiving
a few days later uh very soon later I
deployed them to the uh to Europe
okay so you're not going to be involved
in terms of physically you're not going
to be there so yeah and I I can't be in
the discussions I'm not going to be in
the sort of thing well you can be in
discussions unless you're on some kind
of a mission that doesn't allow
communication with your family
right
very yeah okay all right thank you for
your service
um I'm sorry you guys are facing this
because it's a very it puts a knot in
your stomach because on the one hand you
got the her misbehavior and your
siblings misbehavior with her money that
and all that and on the other hand it's
your mom
right and so it doesn't matter how much
she screwed up should tell your mom
and there's a stop happening so um it
does it it breaks your heart in two
because one side is saying this is
ridiculous and the other side is you
know she's your mom and so um I'm sorry
you guys are in this position but I
would just simply tell everybody we're
going to Medicaid
just find a Medicaid nursing home and
put her in it it's that simple if she
needs care because none of you can
afford to fund it
yeah do you think the question also I
would have is she hasn't had a job in 20
years would that affect an Universal
Security medication anything like that
nope she'll still get the Medicaid
okay and but again you need to read up
on what the exceptions are they used to
be you could keep a home uh with value
uh Equity up to 78 000
um and you could keep a certain amount
of dollars in your checking account and
beyond that they would provide
um I don't know what the numbers are
today I haven't looked it up in a while
but no ancillary things like Kent Browns
or whatever so you're going to be
selling that and giving it to them to
the nursing home but that won't even
last a month so it doesn't matter
between you and me Dave I mean I'm gonna
argue that the house goes too yeah we're
that's fine at this point there's no
reason to have it yeah I don't disagree
but I I think you just go look none of
us can afford it and Medicaid is the
option and this is how we're gonna take
care of her and then you don't have to
get in a big oh you used up all our
money you stole all our money and she
misbehaved and she's not taking care of
it you don't have to get into all that
just take care of her plug her into that
it's the only thing you can do I'm sorry
you're facing it it's all